hello reject nation Greg Alva here and
I'm John Humphrey so we just watched the
Commissioner Gordon meets the team movie
clip I'd liked it John has not been
swayed just yet into a positive
direction alright that's fine
what the goal is watching these is to
get John more excited yes please hyping
up for the writing I'm really trying
your effort alone is making I'm trying
to give you like scenes okay so this one
looks like sounds like you might be a
scene also wanted to give a shout out
today for patreon
James Stegen Jimbo Staggs keep a lookout
for that Commissioner Jim should you use
that on the other video we're gonna
watch the clip Batman meets the flash
I'm still healing I can't hear out of
both of my ears right now but I'm gonna
try to hear this clip oh boy
my special skills include viola web
design fluent in sign language gorilla
sign language silica-based quartz and
fabric brazen resistant heat-resistant
yeah I do
[Music]
[Laughter]
3d is it Batman
so you're fast I feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
to watch your TV the enemies are coming
stop right there
I mean you are yeah I need friends
alright yeah how does a fun scene there
was a fun Sun scene I think that's why
they keep showing that scene that's
gonna be a fun scene we actually watch a
clip of that Superman was more human
than me more show that footage right now
he fell in love and job Superman he's
really seemed to take in a turn first
how he feels about Superman huh yeah a
180 degree turn he's really gotten to
empathize and to you know feel his
struggle since the events of Martha
versus Superman dawn of mothers he did
die for the world he died first and well
he he died for Gotham City Superman did
yeah
when doomsday killed him that's right
yeah and so it's the only way he's not
gonna come back that does make sense we
didn't really have much to say about it
know about that clip I know it was a
plan using it yeah but after watching
this I'm actually really feeling the
journey of Ben Affleck for like putting
together all the like the little scene
the spiderweb connecting of every time
I've seen him interact with the other
characters and the trailer and then
thinking of that clip of Superman was
more human to me and then seeing how he
talks here he kind of has this this
feeling of guilt it looks like he's
trying to feel a little bit more yeah
maybe you know not be as rude yes he was
the last time we saw him yeah like at
all costs I must destroy this guy he
really get a sense that Bruce Wayne is
trying to do the right thing which is
nice yeah and it's that's a good I think
it's a great way to start him off
actually the last clip didn't really
give me much other than okay yeah I get
it he's guilty I kind of picked up on
that from seeing the interaction lately
and then how uncomfortable he can be
with working with other people and if
this is going down a direction of
Nightwing already exists and Batgirl
already exists so that means the bad
family has already broken off and he's
not working with him anymore and the
death of Jason Todd that we see in BVS I
imagine he's had some pretty traumatic
incidences of having to work with other
people so he's been a solo road warrior
when we saw him BBS and then here he has
to deal with that uncomfortableness
gonna learn to love again and he has to
learn to love again and learn to work
with other people himself up to the team
yeah I really picked up on that in Ben
Affleck subtlety see see show us a
couple
season hey I still don't know I don't
know the whole like he's more human than
me I'm like you really like this guy now
compared to the last time I see whatever
John just wait till the movie I will but
hey look we're not done with flash dad's
Batman inspires the flash movie clip I
hope they just drop the whole movie
online they won't John first 45 minutes
we weren't able to put BBS together from
the trailers oh boy oh this scene save
one one which one don't talk don't fight
didn't get one out
[Music]
I'm loving these clips yeah that one
juicy so fun I mean the flash seems fun
that's what I'm getting from all these
is the flashes the is the fundus center
of this movie and I'll give this clip
credit the whole like I've only just
pushed people run away joke has has
never really worked for me up until this
moment okay
seeing the clip around it helps I am
excited to see at least how the flash
interacts with everybody well I love how
just terrified the flashes of this whole
scenario when we see from Batman meets
Flash madmen inspires a flash he's a kid
that is kind of getting mentored by
Deadman right now and I don't think
Batman anticipated this happening yeah I
think Batman was just looking for a guy
with powers but not a kid that he has to
guide I don't know if though like do
some play on that with how he's had like
a couple of Robins at this point and you
know he's at the mentor kids before with
Batman's past yeah or maybe the presence
of Batman guiding flash will give us
audiences a hint at excitement towards
learning about that in the future Batman
in film or whatever
well that really makes me wonder
actually and then talking with you now
has made me think more about it actually
if we are past the bat family and if
we're heading towards a flashpoint I am
curious and now I don't know what what
of that are we going to see if any of it
you know yeah because that's a lot of
history that's very relevant to Batman
into the DC Universe that is in the past
man yes I'm wondering if maybe
flashpoint can get us to a place where
we can actually see some of that I feel
like Batman's growth is gonna be he
learns to be a leader and work with the
team well I would like to see in this
movie happen is there their team
problems happen with Batman not being
able to really leave as well as you like
to handling business like the trailers
make it look like these clips collude to
something like that happening the clips
allude to this might not be such a
smooth process yeah arguably it
shouldn't be I guess it should I feel
like any team coming together movie is
gonna have to do the first the initial
sort of how do we all get along we're
all alphas except for flash and except
for flat and that's really like about
the Barry Allen portrayal
because as a fan of the flash TV show
only two episodes into season four right
now I need to catch up but as a fan of
the flash TV show
he was never portrayed in that show as
like a super petrified guy in that shows
really hot still right now I feel like
if you're gonna go to the theaters
you're gonna want to see a different
interpretation of the flash and this is
so different yeah from these two clips
alone I'm like yeah this is very
different than what the Grant Gustin is
currently doing on the CW show
well even even the small glimpses I've
caught I get the sense for that and I do
appreciate that they have chosen to do
that yeah they've bothered to make this
the movie version very distinct as well
yeah and of all the things about this
movie honestly he's one of the most
distinct things for me going into it
he's one of the things I'm most excited
to see play out as a carrot well he's
not he's the least confident and I love
that approach yeah yeah yeah he's gonna
be the guy I think we're gonna be
rooting for the most out of the Justice
League
yeah for sure for sure because I mean
cyborg looks very methodical and vodka
man just looks like he lives for this
and you know we already know Wonder
Woman we know Batman but yeah Barry
looks like he's gonna be the heart yeah
you know for me and I'm excited to see
him in this actually hey your missions
going a kind of accordion seems to be
warming up a little more James Stegen
Jim oh friend
commissioner Stegen I hope right now you
are enjoying this video while smoking
your cigarettes inside of your apartment
with the windows shut tightly and the
curtains drawn curtains drawn and black
and you have a very serious face on
while listening to us talk about you and
I hope that in the background there's
just the faintest hint of like a wispy
saxophone yeah and I hope you keep
looking off screen like you do in the
Google hangout it's not fully paying
attention to what's going on on the
computer and really thinking about other
things that you'd rather be doing right
now instead of watching us or maybe he's
just looking off-camera it's something
very sinister that we can so maybe we're
on the TV during the Google Hangouts and
so to make eye contact with us we have
to look at the camera on its computer or
maybe
than ever on the TV show us the rest of
your room no it's the rest of your room
and show us that blow-up doll hey
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification - on hungry on Twitter and
Instagram and please become a patron
oject today